hey guys in this video we're gonna talk
about how to relieve neck stiffness and
neck pain okay so I have my friend right
here and we're just gonna kind of show
you some insights on what what's behind
stiffness of the neck okay now the first
thing you need to know is that 90
percent of all the motion in the neck
happen between the skull and the first
bone right up in here okay so when you
turn your head
most the motion is up here not down here
so that's kind of what we're going to be
focusing on with this technique it's
between this first bone called the Atlas
and the skull okay so that's number one
number two so you can see on this
plastic model that there are muscles
tendons and ligaments that tightly
connect the skull to the first bone
right here okay and the second bone as
well so there's a lot of muscles and
ligaments and tendons that are
connecting these two right here and from
whiplash from injury they can get really
really tight okay now one thing you need
to know is that if your digestion is off
if you have a lot of constipation or
bloating there's certain nerves that can
go up to the brainstem and make make
this area very very tight in other words
you can have a lot of neck stiffness
from your digestion so that would
explain the people who do a lot of
massage and chiropractic to the neck but
it keeps coming back over and over and
over in which case you would want to do
some work on the digestive system I put
a link down below how to do that but in
this video we're going to talk
specifically what you do for this upper
upper cervical area right here okay so
the first test we're going to do we're
going to put our thumbs right underneath
your skull and we're going to rock it
back and forth to feel the motion and
you're going to put your thumb on these
little outer projections of the first
cervical vertebra called the transverse
process okay so let's go ahead and do
that right now so the first thing I'm
going to do is we want to just take your
thumbs and kind of dish them underneath
your skull okay right here and then you
want to kind of turn your head left and
right
and what you're looking at what you're
feeling is the symmetry or the movement
of the first bone and see if it's moving
from left to right so you're gonna turn
all the way and turn this way right here
so on me when I go this side I can feel
this does not want to keep going
okay now chiropractic could fix this
pretty quick and I do recommend you find
a chiropractor if you have an obstructed
or a lack of range of motion on this
area however we're going to just work on
the muscles right here so so the
technique of this is you're going to
take your thumb and you're just going to
stretch like three or four times into
the area of restriction okay and then
you're going to just kind of move your
neck around you're gonna see it like
opened up really really nice okay that's
step one so you're basically just
isolating the area of lack of motion
getting it to move better stretching it
and then we're gonna do step two so in
step two what we want to do is you want
to take these ligaments and muscles that
are connecting between the skull and the
first and second bones right here and
we're going to stretch these okay so
this is more of a stretch and we want to
just separate the skull from this first
bone right here so we're going to do
with our thumbs and we're going to be
stretching up this way okay now if you
think about your head is on a little
little rod right here and it's rotating
like this right so we're going to be
stretching all these ligaments and
tendons from here all the way around in
a circular manner right here so right
here we want to stretch this way here
this way okay and then here this way and
then over here so we're going to be
stretching around the central point okay
so I'm going to demonstrate this right
now okay so the first thing you do is
going to take your thumb and you're just
going to take right underneath the skull
and you're going to lift and flex
forward okay so you're going to kind of
you're separating out the distance
between the skull and the first
a cervical vertebra okay so you're gonna
stretch it several times and you're
going to insert them more to the midline
and start to stretch it forward so
you're tucking your chin in like this
and you're lifting the skull you're
creating space okay now we're going to
inch a little bit inward this way and
come up this way
up this way okay and come to the center
right here and then I like to take my
middle finger right here I'm not
flipping you off but I'm going to take
my middle finger and I'm going to take
my thumb and just kind of stretch it so
I can use both hands and I'm lifting up
and going forward okay I'm creating a
space and then I'll take right here and
I'll stretch this way this is the
do-it-yourself version and I'm creating
just a space between here to raise that
up okay so right now my neck feels like
one of those little heads in the back of
the car like the neck is really nice and
loose so go ahead and do this right now
pause the video and come back for step
number three now that you actually open
the space through here okay number three
we're gonna actually work on the muscles
on the front part right here you have a
lot of different muscles and ligaments
that are right underneath the neck that
go to the front part of the spine and
we're gonna stretch that out okay so for
this one you're gonna just take your
thumb okay up underneath this mandible
right here your chin and you're going to
just kind of press up underneath the
muscles it'll be very tender and you're
just going to massage those right here
right here okay you're gonna come right
around and start working the muscles up
underneath this mandible okay and what I
like to do is I like to take my the
muscles here and stretch okay you can do
it one at a time
okay good so now quick little stress
what we do is we kind of loosened up the
front part and now go ahead and move
your neck around should be very nice and
loose so we release the front part and
the back part this is a real quick way
of getting your neck really really loose
so go ahead and try this and put your
comments down below so if you don't have
this book you might want to check it out
it's entitled it's not lose weight to
get healthy it's get healthy to lose the
weight healthy ketosis and intermittent
fasting check it out I put a link down
below